if you're a young person uh it's
important to find marriage Role Models
older couples who have been together for
a while navigated many of the sorts of
challenges that you are facing or will
face and have maintain maintained and
strengthened their bond through it all
uh it's important to find people like
this and hopefully your own parents can
provide that example if not them then
maybe another relative or a friend or
someone else unfortunately there aren't
many public figures who can fill this
role for you if you're looking for a
road map to a healthy marriage the the
celebrity Community isn't the place to
find it but they can still be of some
help you know there aren't many people
in public life who can serve as positive
role models for married couples but
there are plenty who can be negative
Role Models they can show you um they
can't show you which way to go but they
can show you which way you should not go
you can observe them and how they behave
and Endeavor to do the opposite of
whatever they're doing when it comes to
negative Role Models the good news and
also the bad news is that the supply is
endless but perhaps there is no famous
married couple on Earth that has B more
been more helpful in this regard than
Will and Jada Smith that's with all due
respect to Prince Harry and Megan and
John and jezelle fedman and Kim
Kardashian and whoever she's married to
this month Will and Jada are without a
doubt the greatest negative marriage
example you could ever hope to find if
you want a happy and healthy marriage
all you really have to do is uh is just
do nothing that Will and Jada do and
everything they don't do they're like a
lighthouse in a storm except you always
want to go the opposite direction from
wherever this Lighthouse is pointing
that brings us to the latest in the Will
and Jada Horror Story uh the couple has
made it back into the news this week
with Jada now on the interview circuit
to promote her upcoming Memoir which is
called worthy uh I don't know who would
ever purchase a Jada pinket Smith Memoir
but I do know that if I was in charge I
would keep a database of everyone who
purchases the book and I would
immediately and permanently revoke their
voting rights these are the kinds of
fresh ideas we need in Washington but
we're not getting but that's a topic for
another day in any case Jada made a
personal announcement in her Memoir
which came out in her interview with NBC
this week
watch there are so many surprising
things in the book but the thing that
surprised me the most that I actually
had to reread it because I said is this
true right was that in
2016 you and will decided that you were
going to live completely separate lives
it was not a divorce on paper right but
it was a divorce so from the year
2016 which is 7 years ago now yes y all
have
been a part
yeah she she can't even hide her Glee
she's so happy about it she's so happy
about having an estranged being aranged
from her husband now first of all
someone needs to tell the interviewer
that we don't need the clapping sound
effects while she's asking questions but
as for Jada she goes on to explain that
she's living a completely separate life
from Will and that they split up in 2016
because they were exhausted from trying
the words of a true hero this Revelation
is especially humiliating for Will Smith
because everyone immediately drew the
connection to the slap her around the
world and now we know that will not only
embarrassed himself in a desperate
attempt to impress his wife but that he
did all this for a woman who'd left him
five years earlier keep my wife's name
out of your effing mouth he famously
declared but apparently that woman
doesn't really consider herself to be
his wife um Jada you know could have
kept their unique marital arrangement to
herself shielding will from further
embarrassment but then again she has a
memoir to sell so she decided to keep
the separation a secret until she
figured out a way to monetize it of
course this is just the latest and a
long line of ritual public humiliations
Jada has subjected her estranged husband
to there's another one very recently
when she posted an Instagram video of of
her in Tupac in the 90s dancing to Will
Smith's song parents just don't
understand it's well known that Jada
still PS for her deceased lover Tupac so
this was seen by many accurately I think
as a not so subtle dig at the man that
she is still technically married to and
you know that's what she does she finds
little ways to twist the knife it's her
specialty there's uh you know for
example this video from a few years ago
where she decides to film herself not
respecting uh will or his boundaries
watch you know St G is coming to the
table she's going to be at the red table
would you say she has Been instrumental
in you and I redefining our relationship
I would say Don't just start filming me
without asking me oh my goodness if you
can film come help us again please I'm
still dealing with foolishness don't no
no she yeah cuz she don't just would you
say that she helped us heal the hurts
that we cause between one another my
social media presence is my bread and
butter okay so you can't just use me for
social media and not you know don't just
start I'm standing in my house don't
just start
rolling uh that's pretty rough to watch
I think for obvious reasons I I will say
I mean just it's I can't IM my my own
wife I'm just trying to imagine my own
wife first of all filming me without
even asking me for she wouldn't do that
but then if she started to filming and I
said please don't film me and she did it
anyway and then she posted it on the
internet I would be
furious uh fortunately I'm not married
to a woman who would ever do that but
this is this is uh this is Jada pink and
Smith um and pretty rough but of course
nothing
since we're on the subject we we cannot
avoid what is possibly uh one of the
cringiest videos of all time nothing can
possibly compare to the infamous red
table talk where Jada pulled will in to
have a conversation about the time when
she cheated on him uh let's all relive
that cringe
together you during that time launched
into an
interaction with August what do you feel
like um you were looking for I just
wanted to feel good it had been so
long MH since I felt good right and it
was really a joy to just help heal
somebody yeah I think that has a lot to
do with my
codependency which is another thing that
I had to learn to break in the cycle
just that idea of needing to fix and
being drawn to people people that need
help whether it's your health or whether
it's your addictions there's something
about that childhood trauma mhm um that
feels as though it can be fixed through
fixing
people man still tough to watch every
time I I mean imagine your wife cheats
on you and you say to her how could you
do this I'm broken I'm devastated and
she says well I just wanted to feel good
oh okay well if that was your reason but
I wasn't sure what your reason was but
if it was that then never mind and that
was actually somehow the least cringey
segment of that video but the whole
thing is brutal the cuckolded Will Smith
describes his wife's Affair as launching
into an interaction why did you launch
into an interaction with that
man and for her part his wife shows No
Remorse and in fact congratulates
herself on her infidelity by claiming
that she slept with another man in order
to help heal him then to add another
terrible insult to an already Grievous
injury she declares that it makes her
feel good to fix people yet her own
husband is sitting there broken into a
thousand pieces and all this frustration
would build for several years until the
moment when will set his career on fire
by taking it all out on Chris Rock at
the Oscars Jay meanwhile sits there and
watches making no attempt to stop him
from walking up on stage to commit
assault in front of a live audience and
also makes no attempt after the fact to
defend him or come to his Aid in any way
she is in short as I've already dubbed
her the worst wife in America and Will
Smith is without a question the most
pathetic husband In America which is a
sad reality especially when you consider
that before his wife got to work
exposing and humiliating him Will Smith
was it's it's easy to forget now he was
perhaps the most polished cleancut
marketable you know seemingly together
star in Hollywood now he's a laughing
stock thanks to his wife people always
say happy dog happy life it's the Mantra
I live by and you know if it's really
the case you need to be giving your dog
rough greens naturopathic Dr Dennis
black the founder of rough greens is
focusing on focused on improving the
health of every dog in America and
before I started feeding my dog rough
greens I had no idea that dog food is
dead food it contains very little
nutritional value think about it
nutrition isn't Brown it's green but
rough greens bring your dogs food back
to life rough greens is a supplement
that contains all the necessary vitamins
minerals probiotics Omega oils diges of
enzymes and antioxidants that your dog
needs you don't need to go out and buy a
new dog food you just sprinkle rough
Greens on their food every day dog
owners everywhere are raving about rough
greens it supports healthy joints
improves bad breath boosts energy levels
and so much more we are wheat and that
goes for dogs too Dr Dennis black is so
confident rough greens will improve your
dog's health he's offering my listeners
a free jumpstart trial bag so your dog
can try it a free jump start trial bag
can be at your door in just a few
business days go to Ru greens.com or
call 844 ru700 that's rfffg greens.com
/at or call 844 ru700 today you know a
good wife builds her man up a bad one
breaks him down and Will Smith is
nothing at this point if not broken
down that's why they're they they are
such a powerful albeit negative example
they reveal pretty much every facet of a
bad relationship they embody everything
that a married couple can do wrong and
they model one thing in particular and
that is the need for respect in a
marriage especially a man's need for
respect Jada has clearly never respected
her husband and he has never demanded
respect or commanded it most of all and
the end result is is heartache and
humiliation when a man feels respected
at home he'll be happy and confident and
eager and ambitious you know want to go
out and conquer the world because he
feels like his wife respects him and is
proud of him uh you cannot put a price
on that is it's it's impossible to
describe just how important that is to a
man and what it can do for him now when
he's deprived of that respect it's
likely to make him frustrated temper Al
Sullen all the other things that Will
Smith has become in fact the decline of
his career and his Public Image
precisely tracks with the decline of his
marriage the more disrespected he was by
his wife the less respectable he became
this is the way it works you know the
more a man is respected the more
respectable he becomes and the less than
the less the good news is that it's
usually pretty easy to avoid marrying a
woman who doesn't respect you all you
have to do is not marry a woman who
doesn't respect you okay it is that
simple most of the time it's it's
possible is possible that a woman might
hide her inner Jada she might present
herself as wholesome affectionate
respectful supportive um and and when
she's not but most people most women and
most people in general don't have those
talents of deception like Jada pinket
Smith doesn't I saw one clip of her and
I knew everything I needed to know about
her 30 seconds is all it takes it's hard
to believe that will didn't know
there're almost always red flags like
this and most of the time they're
obvious for example uh you know you see
this kind of thing all the time for
people if you're dating
someone and that person ever does or
says anything in
public to intentionally make you look
bad okay we're not talking about just
playful teasing back and forth I'm
talking about they're trying to make you
look bad they're trying to actually
embarrass you if that ever happens that
is a glaring siren telling you to leave
the relationship like if you're if
you're if you're a day before getting
married and that happens leave
immediately you dodged a bullet because
the propensity to publicly belittle and
disrespect you will only get worse not
better and your woman's Instinct uh is
is completely backwards of what it
should be her her Instinct should be to
cover you to prop you up to show that
she's proud of you if someone complains
about you to her she should she should
want to defend you not join in a woman
should brag about the man that she's
with not deliberately try to make him
seem lesser in the eyes of the
public as I've said before my wife's
supportive nature was obvious to me
almost from the moment I met her and it
hasn't changed in 12 years and I'd be
willing to bet a lot of money that
Jada's unsupportive resentful nature her
propensity to humiliate the people she
supposedly loves I I'd be willing to bet
that that was all obvious okay to any
person with eyes and ears from the
moment will m her he ignored those
warning signs and uh now look at him
this is what
happens and it's why both Will and Jada
Smith are today
cancelled hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there